[Musique]
très facile c'est un problème d'habitude
voilà nous ont expérimenté nouvelles
mesures prises par la prévention
routière qui est le port obligatoire du
casque et la ceinture pour les cyclistes
pourquoi ses yeux parce que ça allait
très bien que les cyclistes et les
motocyclistes en ville sont en plus
sujet à des accidents les accidents
graves et c'est souvent la tête qui
prend et les membres les plus importants
alors la prévention routière vient donc
de décider de prendre deux mesures le
port du casque obligatoire
et puis la ceinture trois points c'est
pas difficile à fixer sur le guidon
derrière la scène vous serez bien fort
vous êtes donc solidaire avec le vélo
vous pouvez vous procurer ça chez
n'importe quel garagiste concessionnaire
sans difficulté je crois que c'est une
mesure que l'on peut saluer qui rentrera
en application à partir du 1er mai
[Musique]